John Wick is Keanu Reeves most physical
role and the actor has to be pretty
ripped to play the famed assassin
according to Men's Health Reeves used a
surprisingly limited workout routine to
prepare for the role with just six
Central movements first Reeves performs
a reverse lunge from dumbbell raise
which impacts the legs shoulders and
chest next up there's the bosu Learned
shoulder press this works out the lower
body and shoulders as well as developing
balance then there's the reverse step
resistance band row which continues the
lower body workouts while also working
the back there's also the squat with TRX
shoulder ISO hold which hits the lower
body and shoulders Reeves follows that
with a stability ball Dynamic plank
which develops core strength and balance
he finishes with the banded lateral walk
palaf press which helps to develop
shoulder width and leaves me Immortals
feeling pretty sore the full routine
ensures that a person is both strong and
mobile which comes in handy for martial
arts training